¿Conoces ese momento cuando alguien
te dice que tu historia es un regalo,
que el sufrimiento de tus ancestros
fue en realidad bueno para ti, y no encuentras
las palabras para responder?
No es solo insultante, es la misma
mentira que justifica
por qué 46 de 49 manifestantes
fueron asesinados en regiones
indígenas de Perú en 2022 y 2023.
Te mostraré exactamente cómo
una mentira española de 500 años
se conecta directamente con las balas disparadas
en el pueblo de mi esposa,
con pruebas de más de 40 fuentes
académicas. Mi esposa es de Juliaca, Perú.
Ella es indígena. Vivo
con ella en Ayacucho.
El año pasado en Lima, un propietario español de Airbnb
nos dijo que ella debería estar
agradecida por la colonización,
que España trajo la civilización, liberó
a su gente de la
opresión, les dio derechos.
Me quedé paralizado. Sabía que estaba mal, pero
no tenía las pruebas para demostrarlo.
Millones creen esto.
En Perú, la gente le dice a mi esposa que está
"mejorando la raza",
mejorando su raza al estar conmigo.
Pero hay algo sobre estas afirmaciones
que la mayoría de la gente entiende completamente al revés.
Los españoles dijeron que trajeron
civilización a caníbales y
salvajes. Tu primer instinto
podría ser argumentar que los incas no eran
caníbales. Pero ese es el
enfoque equivocado. La pregunta real
es por qué los informes españoles de repente comenzaron
a llamar caníbales a todos
después de 1503. Colón creó
la palabra caníbal al confundir a pueblos caribeños
llamados "caniba"
con comer carne humana basándose
más en imaginación que en observación. ¿Pero
por qué? Porque en 1503, una
bula papal dijo que podías legalmente
esclavizar a un grupo específico: caníbales.
De repente, todos los grupos que
resistían se convirtieron en caníbales
en los informes españoles. No era antropología,
era un modelo de negocio.
Para Perú, los incas explícitamente
rechazaban comer carne humana.
Excavaciones arqueológicas encontraron, y cito,
"nada que se acerque a los
miles de víctimas" que los españoles
afirmaban. Pero esto es lo que
los españoles realmente encontraron.
Felipe Guamán Poma de Ayala, noble quechua,
pasó 15 años
documentando lo que vio.
1,189 páginas, 398 ilustraciones dibujadas a mano
mostrando a funcionarios españoles
golpeando a mujeres indígenas,
trabajadores llevados a las minas, y sacerdotes
exigiendo favores sexuales.
Los incas eran sofisticados.
Gobernaron 9 millones de personas, construyeron
5,000 kilómetros de redes
de caminos que algunos cronistas
españoles admitieron eran mejores que
los de la antigua Roma. Crearon
arquitectura resistente a terremotos
sin mortero. Los pueblos indígenas tenían
tres principios fundamentales.
Ama suwa, no robes,
ama llulla, no mientas, y ama quella, no
seas perezoso. Los españoles violaron los tres.
Robaron 24 toneladas de oro solo de Atahualpa.
Mintieron sobre
proporcionar protección, y
forzaron a los pueblos indígenas a trabajos
brutales mientras extraían riquezas. Los
españoles no trajeron
civilización. La destruyeron. Los
españoles destruyeron la civilización
más sofisticada
de Sudamérica. Convirtieron esas mismas
regiones en zonas
de extracción. 500 años después,
esas mismas regiones siguen siendo
atacadas. Eso no es
coincidencia. Es continuidad.
Pero tal vez estés pensando que los incas
no eran ángeles. También tenían trabajo forzado.
¿No hace eso que la liberación española
sea parcialmente cierta? Aquí
es donde se pone oscuro.
Noviembre de 1532, la trampa de Pizarro se cierra.
Atahualpa es capturado.
Ofrece sus riquezas
como rescate. Llenaría una habitación de 24
pies de largo, 18 pies de ancho,
hasta donde alcanzara su mano con oro,
y dos habitaciones más del mismo tamaño con plata. Pizarro
acepta. Llega el oro.
24 toneladas de oro, derretidas
desde objetos sagrados incas. Pizarro lo acepta
todo y luego ejecuta a Atahualpa de todas formas.
Lo obligan a convertirse, le dan
un nombre cristiano, luego lo estrangulan
en lugar de quemarlo como amenazaron,
porque convertirse significaba que su cuerpo podía
permanecer intacto. Ese fue
su trato de misericordia, estrangulación en lugar
de quemarse vivo. Pero ejecuciones como estas
no eran el verdadero genocidio. Entre
1520 y 1620, la población de Perú colapsó
de 5 a 9 millones a solo 600,000,
un declive del 90%.
Eso es más que la peste negra de Europa.
Las enfermedades mataron a la mayoría, viruela
y sarampión, tifus,
pero ese no es el argumento salvador que la gente
piensa. Los españoles
crearon las condiciones perfectas
para que esas enfermedades arrasaran. Reasentamientos
forzados, reducciones, 1.4
millones de personas obligadas
a vivir en pueblos planificados para que los
españoles pudieran controlarlos más fácilmente. Las enfermedades
se propagaron más rápido en esas
poblaciones concentradas. Los sistemas agrícolas fueron
destruidos. La gente murió de hambre mientras
los españoles los obligaban a extraer plata. El
trabajo forzado aceleró el agotamiento
y la muerte. La enfermedad no fue
un desafortunado accidente natural. Fue
amplificada por la política
española, y eso nos lleva a Potosí,
la montaña que consumió vidas.
Un fraile dominico lo llamó "boca del infierno"
en la década de 1550.
El sistema de la mita obligaba a los hombres indígenas
a trabajar en esas minas. Las provincias
tenían que enviar el 16% de los hombres adultos
anualmente, más de 13,000 trabajadores
al año en el pico. Eran marchados
cientos de kilómetros desde sus
hogares. Trabajaban en temperaturas de 50 grados Celsius,
cargando 300 libras, inhalando vapor
de mercurio que los mató en años. El
consenso académico conservador dice que más
de 1 millón murieron solo en Potosí.
Algunos dicen 8 millones
contando todas las minas andinas. Las provincias
de la mita perdieron el 60% de su población
indígena para 1683. Eso va más allá
de la enfermedad. Eso es extracción letal. Un
estudio de 2021 probó que los antiguos distritos
de la mita todavía tienen peores carreteras,
educación y economía 400
años después. La explotación colonial
tiene efectos compuestos que nunca desaparecen.
Los españoles defendieron todo esto con
leyes que nunca cumplieron. Las Nuevas Leyes
de 1542 supuestamente terminaban con la esclavitud indígena.
El Rey envió a su primer virrey a Perú para
hacerlas cumplir. Los colonos rebeldes
lo decapitaron en 1546.
La respuesta del Rey fue revocar las leyes
en un año. Las ganancias importaban más que
las vidas indígenas. Después de que Perú ganara
la independencia en 1821, la explotación
continuó. Los pueblos indígenas esperaron
154 años para el reconocimiento oficial del quechua.
Eso fue en 1975. 190
años para el derecho a consulta previa.
Eso fue en 2011. Y cuando
esas consultas finalmente suceden,
las organizaciones indígenas las llaman
"simulaciones". El gobierno procede
con proyectos mineros sin importar el consentimiento. Ahora
aquí está el truco ideológico que
mantiene todo esto vivo: el
mestizaje. Los defensores lo llaman
"todos estamos mezclados", democracia
racial. Pero así es como
realmente funciona: crea una jerarquía.
Blanco arriba, indígena abajo, mestizo en el medio.
Movilidad ascendente supuestamente posible, pero solo
abandonando la identidad indígena,
hablando español, mudándote a la ciudad,
olvidando de dónde vienes. Funciona
como defensa y jerarquía
simultáneamente. Y España todavía defiende
esto hoy. En 2019,
el presidente de México pidió a España
que se disculpara por los abusos coloniales. La
respuesta de España: "La llegada de los españoles
no puede juzgarse a la
luz de consideraciones contemporáneas". En
otras palabras, el genocidio no puede
juzgarse por los estándares morales
de hoy. Esa es la posición oficial
de España. España todavía
celebra el 12 de octubre como
"Día de la Hispanidad", celebrando el
comienzo de la colonización. Pero seamos
claros sobre cómo esta
mezcla realmente sucedió. La mayor parte de esta
mezcla en el primer siglo de
colonización sucedió a través
de violación. Las mujeres indígenas no tenían opción.
Los hombres españoles reclamaron derecho de conquista
sobre los cuerpos de las mujeres,
tal como reclamaron la tierra. Hoy
empaquetan esta violencia como
"todos estamos bellamente mezclados".
Le dicen a mi esposa que está mejorando su
raza, como si la mezcla original
fuera voluntaria, como si no
fuera trauma pasado a través de
generaciones. Convirtieron evidencia de violación
en identidad nacional,
luego le dijeron a los descendientes que estuvieran agradecidos.
Están rebranding
violencia sexual como progreso,
tal como rebrandearon extracción como
desarrollo y genocidio como civilización.
La académica Marisol de la Cadena documentó
cómo funciona. "Mejoras
tu raza acumulando
dinero, yendo a universidades caras,
cambiando de barrio,
olvidando de dónde vienes.
Los pueblos indígenas deben cometer
des-indianización para escapar
de la discriminación. Y así es como la mentira
se reproduce. Un amigo colombiano
fue a una escuela católica fundada en
1604. Cuatro siglos
después, todavía enseñan que
Colón trajo
civilización. Sin mención del genocidio,
sin mención de esclavitud, sin mención de
violación. Las escuelas mismas
son infraestructura colonial,
todavía funcionando, todavía mintiendo. Eso
no es educación, es
adoctrinamiento que ha estado
operando por 400 años."
El sociólogo peruano Aníbal Quijano
llamó a esto "colonialidad".
Estructura colonial que sobrevive después de
que termina el colonialismo. El poder
colonial no muere. Sobrevive.
Se adapta. Un estudio de historia económica de 2021
probó que los antiguos distritos
de la mita todavía tienen peores resultados
400 años después. Son las regiones
más pobres hoy. Las mismas
regiones donde murieron manifestantes en
2022 fueron 75% de las víctimas en el conflicto de 1980
a 2000 de Perú eran
hablantes de quechua. La extracción
nunca se detuvo. Solo cambió
de administración. En 2024, arqueólogos
escanearon 179,000 kilómetros cuadrados
de los Andes usando IA satelital. El 95% de
las celdas de la cuadrícula no muestran
rastros arqueológicos. Donde
las comunidades indígenas alguna vez prosperaron, ahora
solo vacío. Ese
vacío es disrupción colonial
visible desde el espacio. Los españoles trajeron
tres cosas a Perú. Muerte
para el 90% de la población,
extracción que continúa hoy, y mentiras
sobre ambas. Y estas
mentiras no son únicas de Perú.
Las mismas escuelas, la misma mejora
a través de violación rebrandeada como mezcla, la
misma violencia contra
quienes resisten se enseña en Bogotá,
Ciudad de México y Santiago.
500 años de resistencia desde
Atahualpa hasta Túpac Amaru hasta los manifestantes
en 2023. La misma lucha, las mismas
regiones, el mismo rechazo
a aceptar una mentira. Comparte esto con cualquiera
que piense que la colonización fue civilizadora.
Las fuentes están abajo.
Y si quieres más desmantelamientos basados en evidencia
de propaganda histórica,
suscríbete. Historia versus
hype. La evidencia vence
a la mitología cada vez.